hello and welcome to Friday re if you
didn't know if I dairies I look back at
my weekend blog for him right now I'm in
Anaheim wearing a lavender jumpsuit but
I didn't start the week this way let's
see how my week began you have had this
toy for five minutes you go right for
the heart and there it is that was the
heart no don't eat the heart don't eat
the heart new toys in town happen to the
old time oh yes you're so innocent cute
hi guys happy Monday it is Monday isn't
Monday it is Monday
happy Monday you guys I just posted
earlier today a video with Anna Akana
that I am really excited about she was
on an episode of nacho deep my audio and
video podcast and we shot a video for my
channel in correlation with that where
we did the balloon challenge so if you
haven't watched it it's on this channel
go watch it
um this is happening and I just got back
from the Grove with mamrie Hart we went
shopping for VidCon by the time Friday
eree goes up I will I will already be at
VidCon so I am chess right now watching
a prank first prank and I'm trying to
figure out what I want to wear yes very
squeak much frustrating dang a bar got
some pizzas and french fries are these
like dumb these might be really dumb and
like the bad way dumb I don't know I
might wear them though I've already
stanked them up with my feet juices so
can't take them back
yeah hey guys I'm at pump restaurant
from the Bravo reality series Vanderpump
rules and I just want to show you how
kuda bathrooms huh look at this well
well well I don't understand how boys
pee but very cool very cool people
watching snapchat back after they happen
Oh Meredith
my handiwork ready oh my gosh is that a
dog it does look like a dog or a dog
song yeah it's very good your
handwriting is better than you thought
it was yeah I look like I have just
really bad wrinkles on my fork looks
like you're thinking really hard about
this is what I'm gonna look like as an
old man what do you think um things have
transpired uh this is quite a what is
today Wednesday morning although how
you're holding the mic here like I know
you're talking into it
yeah I'm not holding it I mean like guys
things have happened I think we just
invented we reinvented say anything
truly and also I kind of like myself
with the mustache I'm sorry cuz I'm
looking at my own face right now or
foreheads I'm hanging out with some
friends tonight
good morning VidCon hi sorry that's not
for you well I should say it's not just
for you for everyone I made it down to
Anaheim for VidCon here's my lovely view
then there are balconies that people sit
on there I get to look at them I'm a
very flattering down angle and this just
happened and I am being a professional
adult and I'm going to iron my clothes
while I wait for Diane to bring me red
balls cuz adult nice this is important
business yay giving makeup done to go
talk to Katie Couric because all of that
is normal look who's here doing the
makeup yeah
I'm look who's down there just creeping
on everybody in the courtyard
this new height character that I am -
it's all de convención Diane is in full
effect on some red wine no big deal
about to do a signing but night but not
a photo Inge yeah
hi guys it is 6 p.m. on Friday and I am
so tired and this is day 2 of VidCon
technically and tomorrow is my biggest
day yet at VidCon I get to meet more of
you I got to meet a bunch of you this
morning it's so fun I'm headed out a
little bit go to some other events
tonight I'm just so tired yeah it's the
last day of VidCon and we're in the
green room waiting to go do it our side
and look how festive and exciting the
green room is yes yes yes yes
Hannah you look different I just got
done my second Meetup my final meetup
that later today we have a Q&A I'm
wearing a lavender jumpsuit I'm feeling
like Martha Stewart meets ghostbusters
when DJ Diaz put purple on my eyes wat
and I just want to take a moment to
appreciate the amazing gifts you guys
brought me this morning I got a french
fry lunchbox with lunchbox
a french fry lunchbox with snacks inside
and other secrets you made shirts with
goose look at that maniac
French Bulldog socks what are these how
why there's so many wonderful wonderful
things here
poutine flavored ruffles uh it's about
food time for those to be in my life
thank you guys thank you think you think
you think you take you and
Chris I learned how to curl my hair but
I really shouldn't be in before I drink
there you go there's look back in my
week it's been really amazing becomes
not completely done but I want to thank
you to everyone that I've been able to
say hi to and it's been so cool I'm
hoping that you are having a great
moment in I don't know are you cheat
Alicia's I'm at always cheetalicious